showbiz Yannick Noah pourquoi je reste
en France réponse parce que j'ai pas les
couilles de partir
j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir pour sa revue
de 13 de la semaine
à toi Stéphane
[Musique]
lundi de la Pentecôte rien pas de vanne
je refuse de travailler pour les vieux
c'est confirmé MAM a une haleine de bouc
un scoop si Ségolène avait gagné
François Hollande avait lu aussi réservé
un yacht un peu moins cher que celui de
Bolloré 78 euros et 60 centimes
la star là si tu bandes pas c'est moins
grave
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas Sarkozy à bord du futur A380 qui
pourra je le rappelle transporter 830
sans papiers d'un coup
Nicolas a testé une nouvelle manette un
système de trappe pour évacuer en plein
vol les récalcitrantes c'est plus humain
voilà
et dans les Pyrénées une belle image de
solidarité une voiture sinistrée s'est
échoué au pied d'un homme politique
sinistré aussi
faits divers la belle fille de Nicolas
Sarkozy renversée par un scooter et on a
enfin un portrait robot du chauffard
voilà
[Applaudissements]
imitateur en herbe attention et là je
m'adresse à Liane Foly en Corse du Sud
de zimitations de Mike Brant on tournait
au drame
là on va monter en pression
artificielle encore des progrès à faire
dans match Céline Dion nous présente son
fils
[Applaudissements]
sport Laure Manaudou blessé au doigt de
pied son ex entraîneur est furieux un
accident prévisible selon lui et
regardez ces images en pleine séance
d'apnée le nageur italien qui a quitté
sa ligne d'eau lui écrase leur tête leur
alourdit par les deux sacs de McDo
qu'elle vient de s'enfiler n'a plus
éviter le choc
showbiz Yannick Noah pourquoi je reste
en France réponse parce que j'ai pas les
couilles de partir
[Applaudissements]
n'est pas une girouette dans Le Parisien
du 25 mai Roland-Garros je m'en fous et
dans le VSD du 26 mai Yannick Noah
raconte son langage
[Applaudissements]
le canard est doté d'un pénis de 30 cm
une info qui est une info qui a fait
beaucoup de mal à Stéphane
bernes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des fables de Stéphane
il y en a deux à Orly drame évitez de
justesse une vieille chouette failli
boucher un réacteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
télévision Line Renaud et Arditi réunies
dans une série pour France 2 ok ok je
bosserai pour les vieux à la Pentecôte
c'est promis mais en échange que les
vieux arrêtent de bosser voilà
c'est fini demain c'est la fête des
mères Michel Alliot-Marie et Amanda Lear
c'est dans 15 jours pour la fête des
pères
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu